bring it back to the center take a pawn
try and bring that black queen back into
the defense but there's so many good
moves actually i mean looking at the
position i mean that's just one line
that you
you've kind of shown but i can actually
see other scenarios where okay so the
rook moves and now the bishop can
actually move to the g5 square okay but
magnus is frowning maybe he realizes
it's actually checkmate in three with
the variation i showed yeah as you
mentioned ivanka you can bring your
bishop to other squares and it's game
over i think but actually if you bring a
bishop the king goes to g7 now i missed
this um
and it says 100 on the bar okay it's on
the board david and naraditsky did you
see that he applauded
that's the streamer that's a streamer
he's also a streamer because he lets the
checkmate happen on the board no
resignation he shows the fans why the
game ends and that's checkmate
wow well uh magnus carlsen he was
checkmated against dollars of russia but
he checkmates uh daniel naradicki in the
next game a win for magnus carlsen in
this